here's Trump a couple days ago talking
to the nelk boys about Florida and it's
just it's just nonsense it's just
nonsense
why do you think he's well like besides
that because he's done a pretty good job
with Florida you agree why do you think
you're a better choice than DeSantis
well actually if you look at the numbers
he didn't do a great job if you take a
look at the numbers he's very high on
crime very high right at the top uh
almost at the top uh he I think he gets
good publicity although now people are
starting because I'm putting out the
covet numbers he didn't do well on covet
he had more deaths and almost every
country in Florida I hate to say it
because Florida's my state but he had he
did not have he did not do well it's
it's really it's very interesting I
don't want to knock anybody but the
thing he did well on his public
relations because the numbers weren't
what uh they pretended to be with all of
that being said when you help somebody
I believe in loyalty you just don't do
what he did now he's out campaigning I
assume he's going to run but I think the
numbers are so bad now that a lot of
people are assuming that he won't run
and uh would you consider him like to be
your running mate I don't I I don't see
it I mean I don't see all right there's
just so much nonsense there look we've
played the videos before and I'm sure
we'll play them again I didn't feel like
doing it today there are a million
videos of trump all throughout covid
praising DeSantis right he's the best
he's keeping the state open I love the
guy I wish Michigan could be more like
Florida
etc etc uh the numbers also you know the
numbers of deaths first off Florida has
the second oldest population right
what's the joke about Florida right you
guys know this is this is where people
go to die this is this is Golden Girls
country uh now it happens to be uh
getting much younger and it's
flourishing in the business but you have
to blend controlling people's lives with
safety uh so it's just a absolute lie
about the numbers also we have good
weather here so you open up earlier
people get out and about uh does Trump
want to start talking about the fact
that he was the one that pushed for warp
speed and now his own base which is the
most anti-vax people out there uh all or
many of them got injected or were forced
to get injected or were friends or
spouses was someone who got forced to be
injected and mandates and all of the
stuff so he's just lying about Florida
and again two of his kids moved down
here with their children during covid
his whole family lives down here you can
find a million videos again I don't want
to be gratuitous about this which is why
I'm trying to do this in some kind of
measured way but you can find a
gajillion videos of Don Jr who I'm
friends with and I hope he's not pissed
at me you can find videos of him talking
about how great Florida is you can find
videos you could it was my my own show
where he opened for me at uh at the West
Palm Beach uh improv but we did an hour
on how freaking great Florida is so it's
just nonsense
[Music]
thank you